Andrew Tate's the most famous man you've
probably never heard of the chances are
your children will have videos of today
they've been viewed billions of Times
online he's built an enormous following
of mostly young men and this is often
scandalous views about women that have
made him notorious across the World
Views like this
so I think my sister is my her husband's
property yes when a bride is walking
down the aisle to marry the groom the
father walks next to her and gives her
away true or false
takes opinions on mental illness are
equally controversial
I don't believe
don't message me about the question
because I don't believe in it if you're
asleep in your bed in the middle of the
night and you hear a noise and you
believe in ghosts now you're afraid but
if you don't believe in ghosts oh it's
the wind and you go back to sleep you
give the ghosts Power by believing in
them
well there's some every major social
media platform band Tate amid a global
backlash and concerns about his
influence on the young people who watch
him but copies of his videos are still
shared millions of times every day this
show is called uncensored what are the
challenges used directly so he flew from
Romania to sit here in this studio and
the full explosive interview as later
this week here's a bit of what's has
come
do you respect women absolutely why
wouldn't I do you think the 18 19 year
old woman are more attractive than 25
year old woman I think there's
Attractive people uh that's that's a
loaded question I don't know it's not
really is it I I can't know why I'm
asking you of course I do but I can't
sit here so the benefit of you is you
don't know why I'm asking you said this
in general this is also one of the
reasons men find youth attractive you
want to block the internet or block the
internet write a thing now the reason 18
and 19 year olds are more attractive
than 25 year olds is because they've
been through less dick people say oh you
can't say that but yes I can a 19 year
old is more attractive than 26 year old
woman and I'll tell you why because that
26 year old has talked to more guys been
to the club more times being effed and
dumped more times more arguments more
mass more for me to clean up that is
misogyny why because you are encouraging
a mindset about 25 year old women that
makes them sound out to be
infinitely less desirable than 18 19
year olds and having effectively been
having too much sex to be taken in a
more respectful way that would well
firstly even if that was the case they
wouldn't be misogyny but what did you
mean by what you said that's not
misogyny because it's not anti-women I'm
saying that an 18 or a 19 year old woman
would be more desired pretty anti-25
year old woman anti-25 year old women we
can argue but not misogyny well that's
misogynistic no no no it's not being
anti-any woman at all is misogynist not
when I'm not what I'm saying that women
are beautiful and attractive at a
certain age and saying the ages you're
saying 18 19 I was more attractive than
21 other than ageist perhaps but
misogynistic absolutely but you just
accepted it was misogyny no I didn't you
said it was massaging I'm telling you no
it's not but if a 26 year old woman is
watching this and has heard those
comments would you just say to her look
I'm sorry I shouldn't have said that no
I won't I will say that I am sorry that
that offends you however there's a large
contingent of the world it doesn't mean
you're sorry no I'm not sorry that's the
point I'm making I'm sorry if that
offends you however there's a large
contingent of the world that believed
that and I was mediating for a
conversation parts of the world that
believed that about 26 year old women
are parts of the world where women are
not allowed out on their own that's your
that's a conversation wear full burkas
well that's a conversation they're not
allowed to drive cars that's nothing to
do with it but is that the kind of world
for a woman I was mediating I was
mediating a conversation I'm asking you
what you think I I don't live in a
country where that happens you're using
that as the excuse for why you're not
sorry for saying it there are parts of
the world but this is fine so my
question to you is what do you think
it's fine I don't think it's fine I live
in a world where you don't think it's
fine my the reason this isn't that hard
Andrew you can simply say beers you know
what with the benefit of hindsight I
wish I hadn't said it like that and if a
26 year old woman's watching I'm sorry I
said that because that actually is
blatantly misogynist and even though
that's a view held by other parts of the
world it's not a view I share now I
would respect you more if you said that
yeah and if you try and say Well it said
in other parts of the world so I'm not
sorry I think that doesn't tell me what
you think then you need to understand
why my content existed in the first
place my content existed because I tried
my very hardest to be an absolute not a
realist especially with uncomfortable
truths I was pointing out that very
uncomfortable is that a truth it's an
uncomfortable truth in many parts of the
world it's not a proof that I'm happy
about an inquest this week found that
the 14 year old girl Molly Russell died
from an active self-harm while suffering
from depression and the negative effects
of online content the coroner said she
was exposed to material that may have
influenced her in a negative way and in
addition I started this depression and
become a much more serious depressive
illness and she's very sadly took her
life that's that's absolutely disgusting
right her father terrible her father's
campaign for better protections against
potentially dangerous social media
algorithms right it says that the
particularly graphic contents you saw
romanticized acts of self-harm
normalized her condition and focused on
a limited and irrational view without
any counterbalance of normality
first of all what is your response to
that nothing to do with you yes that's
the first thing yeah it is nothing to do
with me the fact that a 14 year old girl
took her life is truly sad the world we
live in today is
the world we live in the fact that
something like that happened is almost
mind-blowing to me that's truly that's
truly sad I actually feel sad inside to
see something like that what has come
clear to me in the interview is that a
lot of things you say you wouldn't say
now that you've said before I say I'd
say differently yeah right so to me
that's an acceptance
not just that you want to get back on
platforms because maybe that was one of
the reasons you you were no platform but
you've recognized and understood the
potential harm to the wrong kind of
impressionable mind
by some of the things you've said would
that be fair I think that's 80 fair I
recognize and understand that with
massive Fame
you have to be more careful about being
misconstrued like I said earlier one
percent of people misunderstanding you
doesn't matter with a small audience it
matters with a very large audience with
power comes responsibility I still
believe the things I say I do not want
to be a negative Force for the world I
also understand that I am a man who's
lived a very difficult nuanced life and
I am capable of making nuanced points
that may be misunderstood by teenagers
however that can be said about anybody
and everything every opinion online can
be misunderstood by children trying to
protect children from the Internet is a
very interesting subject in and of
itself because I would argue that 80 of
the content on the Internet is can be
negative or detrimental to a young mind
that doesn't understand the world